[Music]
[Music]
hello I'm Brian Karras technical
director of graphics here at Epic Games
hi I'm Jonathan objective a special
project a few years ago we got together
as a team and brainstormed where we
thought we could push forward
state-of-the-art in real-time graphics
there are two key areas that stood out
the first dynamic global illumination
beautiful bounc lighting instantaneously
I don't have to be constrained to do a
game where the world has to be static
and I'm able to attach a lot faster and
we call this new system lumen we're
about to show you what it is capable of
but first there was another area that we
thought we can push forward truly
virtualized geometry the artist wouldn't
have to be concerned over poly counts
draw calls or memory we directly use
film quality assets and bring them
straight into the engine and that's a
big deal parties I just want to be able
to import my ZBrush model my
photogrammetry scan my CAD data without
wasting any time optimizing creating
melodies or even lowing the quality to
make it hit frame rate and the end
that's what it's all about art that just
works and we call this new technology
nammai here is the future of Unreal
Engine running live on a Playstation 5
awesome let's take a look at it this has
to be
[Music]
before we continue let's stop a moment
and take a look at some of the key
features of this demo much of what you
see was built with quick so Meg Ascan
assets but instead of using the game
versions we use the cinematic versions
which would typically only be used in
film there are around a million
triangles each and thanks to virtual
texturing they all use 8k textures as
well nanoq can render an insane number
of triangles very quickly there are over
a billion triangles of source geometry
in each frame the nanite crunches down
losslessly to around 20 million at drawn
triangles what does that many triangles
look like this isn't noise these are the
triangles each a different color most
are so small that they look like noise
nanite achieves detail down to the pixel
which means triangles are often the size
of pizzas this amount of geometric
detail requires shadows to be pixel
accurate as well and then I can do that
too speaking of lighting all of the
lighting in this demo is completely
dynamic with the power of lumen that
even includes multi bounds global
illumination no light Maps no baking
here without GI all of that beautiful
lighting is gone with lumen enabled we
can move the light and the bounce
changes instantly ok let's keep going
which made some great additions to our
audio system as well
convolution reverb allows us to measure
reverberation characteristics of real
spaces like actual caves that we sampled
and reproduce them in virtual spaces
sound field rendering allows us to
record and playback spatialized audio
all of this adds up to a more immersive
experience this swarm of bats was
created with a Niagara effects system
particles in Niagara can now talk to one
another and understand their environment
like never before
we've also added a ton of new
functionality to run fluid simulations
like you see in the water below
the demo runs on our Kaos physics system
here we are using it to accurately
simulate the rigid bodies of the falling
rocks and the cloth of her scarf
[Music]
Oh
now that the environment is so complex
we've needed to greatly improve our
animation systems to adapt with added
predictive foot placement and motion
warping which dynamically modifies I K
and body position to look more natural
for the character to more realistically
interact with the environment we've
added the ability to trigger seamless
contextual animation events like her
hand on the door Thomas
dynamic TI is amazing not just for
speeding up iteration but also for its
impact on gameplay any light source can
move while still having beautiful bounce
lighting dynamic illumination means
specular as well which you can see on
all the metal surfaces you can even see
the Niagra powered bugs reacting to the
light lumen not only reacted to moving
light sources but also changes in
geometry
remember we mention high poly assets
this statue is imported directly from
ZBrush and is more than 33 million
triangles no baking of normal Maps no
authored LEDs and we can do more than a
single statue there are nearly 500 of
that exact statue at the same detail
level placed in this room for a total of
over 16 billion triangles from statues
alone
[Music]
over this entire demo there are hundreds
of billions of triangles
[Applause]
[Music]
so with nanite you have limitless
geometry and with lumen you have fully
dynamic lighting and global illumination
all running on a Playstation 5
[Music]
there's not much time
and this doesn't need to be constrained
to small rooms it can stretch all the
way to the horizon
the portal is open
it's time to see what's next
[Music]
you
there you go the Unreal Engine 5 is real
and that was the first real-time footage
of something running on the PlayStation
5 as well such a amazing day I think for
gamers to get a glimpse it's where games
are going next and now it's my honor to
be joined by three guys from epic to
talk a little bit about today's
announcement of course we've got Tim
Sweeney kim library and nick Penn Warren
and guys thanks for joining me here
virtually this is a really big and
exciting day I mean I think I'm just was
so blown away when I saw this footage
about what ue5 can do and Tim this is I
know a special moment for you to have
you know put a 5 on this Unreal Engine I
remember the first time you showed me
the original Unreal Engine I think was
like 1996 at e3 at a Marriott Marina del
Rey and and I was looking back last
night at like the old next-generation
magazine cover with like can you believe
this is what a PC screenshot of the
original Unreal Engine how far we've
come tell me I mean you know this is a
big moment for epic but what does this
mean to sort of the company right now to
be able to you know they view the first
PlayStation 5 footage but also you know
introduce you know a new numbered
version of unreal
well this really is a generational leap
or more and technological capabilities
and the this the hardware that Sony is a
launching is absolutely phenomenal
not only an unprecedent above graphics
power but also a completely new storage
architecture that loves it those past
architectures out of the water and far
ahead of even the state-of-the-art and
the highest NPCs you can buy and so with
under one Gen 5 we set out to build a
new generation of technology that
empowers creators to create
photorealistic scenes they're
indistinguishable from reality and to do
so with a very high degree of
productivity right I mean there are two
problems in the in game development
right one is a the the features needed
to achieve complete realism but the
other big problem is the just the cost
and time it takes for an artist to
create a major new piece of content for
a next-generation game and so under 1 CH
and 5 attacks both of the
problems we have the nanite system for
virtual geometry enabling sub-pixel
geometry which is imperceptibly just
impressively different from the you know
full high-quality asset so the movie
quality assets that were originally
scanned also the lumen of real-time
global illumination system not only to
bring unprecedented quality inviting to
the environments but also to free
artists from having to worry about the
details of lighting their levels and
make all these set trade-offs and Static
lighting versus dynamic lighting and so
we're really trying to empower
developers here I'm and to enable
developers to create an in generation of
experiences that are both unbelievably
realistic but also economical and
practical for them to create without
having to have a thousand person team
yeah I mean when you look at that
footage you know in 4k I mean just that
the level of detail is absolutely
stunning can maybe you could break down
a little bit of this you know sort of
usually what's happening that makes it
look so incredible design oh you've got
a couple of new systems that you're
really proud of and maybe talk about
nanite and what that is and how it works
and how it's gonna kind of shape games
moving forward okay so is a system for
Unreal Engine that lets us get down to
almost sub pixel levels of detail on the
screen you know it's cable but it's
possible because we have a new
generation of hardware that really
allows us to put loads and loads of
triangles of the screen and we thought
that we'd come up with a new technique
that allowed us to be able to create
content in a similar way to the way that
they do on movies today so in fact when
you look at that demo all the masses
nana is basically ingesting all the
movie quality assets from quick solve to
make that scene and the audience doesn't
even have to think about it they can
move rocks and mountains and statues
wherever they want in the scene and not
have to worry about triangle costs
anymore aluminium the global
illumination system that Tim mentioned
that just produces incredibly realistic
and accurate bounce lighting so wherever
you place a light in the scene its
effect on the whole world is seen
instantly by just moving things around
it's amazing yeah I saw that demo I was
just so blown away by
the visual fidelity and also I think how
much felt at least to me is an end-user
how much felt that so much of the
environment was streaming in in real
time in so much detail especially that
sequence where she's flying through the
environment mark Cerny has talked a lot
about playstation 5 and the you know the
incredible you know bandwidth it's gonna
have to you know move data from the SSD
you know right on to screen it can you
maybe talk a bit about how that's sort
of manifesting itself in this demo I
assume some of you know those
improvements in PS 5 or enabling types
of things that just weren't possible in
previous generations yeah so then I able
the artist to build a scene with
geometric complexity that would have
been impossible before there are tens of
billions of triangles in that scene and
we simply couldn't have them all in
memory at once and so what we end up
needing to do is streaming in triangles
as the cameras moving throughout the
environment and the i/o capabilities of
playstation 5 are one of the key
hardware features that enable us to
achieve that that level of realism yeah
no it's it's stunning to see that and I
think also you know the global
illumination I think people have you
know heard that concept before but now
you know really manifesting sort of in
real-time in that environment with you
know the flashlight or some of the other
you know lighting scenes can you guys
maybe break down sort of you know on the
from the gamer perspective like how
games are gonna change because of the
the full global illumination
well yeah first of all this enables a
much wider variety of games to have a
very realistic responses to light you
know everything from you know from
large-scale open-world types of the
games you know with day/night cycles
being seamless transitions from indoor
to outdoor it's just it makes sightings
one of the things that the developers
don't have to worry about and you know
it's a it's a freeing technology not
only does it mean more real-time
fighting in games but it also means
there's a large set of problems that
were very tricky in the previous
generation that developers just don't
need to worry about and so I think
you're going to see how much wider
variety
types of games taking advantage of lumen
and taking advantage of nanite and well
the one that core elements of every new
generation transition is new hardware
capabilities with an order of magnitude
improvement over previous generations
enable entirely new types of games to
develop the Battle Royale John I didn't
even take off until the current
generation where you finally had enough
computing and graphics power to enable a
hundred player game you know with very
very high fidelity encounters and this
new generation of technology that we're
building with on your one Gen 5 and Sony
is empowering with PlayStation 5 weren't
able entirely new types of game
experiences that we can't even
anticipate yet yeah there's been a lot
of talk over the you know past couple
weeks about you know the next generation
kind of you know will the leap be as
great as previous generations what are
the types of things we're gonna see I
think this demo at least to me you know
is the first kind of real-time example
of something that really grabs me and I
just want to confirm like what we're
seeing there that's all like you can
actually play that with a controller
like that's not kind of frame dumped or
anything that's actually playable and
recording the signal that came out over
HDMI so except totally like demo and
it's replayable and it's a little bit
different every time player Wow no just
I mean that that flight sequence alright
that's what's so exciting to me is like
this is you know real-time footage so
what do you guys think I mean when
people say like you know what is the
leap of this generation gonna be to sort
of you know previous generations from
like PlayStation 3 to 4 or whatnot is it
is it any different this time is it
gonna be greater or less or we don't
know yet I think offensive immersion you
know one of the great things about
playing games is you transport it to
places that you could never go in the
normal world
this level of line of lighting in detail
really get you to a point where you
feeling like you're inside a movie
Sadler it's the things as low realistic
and he's just gonna he's gonna aid the
storytelling I think that sense of
immersion the feeling of player gets
from actually visiting a space well Mike
will be much deeper than you've ever
seen before and the ability of the
hardware and the entrant is
and massive amounts of content as you're
going through a huge environment I think
that's going to have a much bigger
impact on on gaming than people are
expecting right now you know until this
next generation of hardware previous
generation console games had to be built
to load data off of a spinning
mechanical device right as its roots and
the 1950s and now Sony's storage system
is absolutely world-class you know not
only the best in class and console but
also the best on any platform better
than high-end PC I think this is going
to enable the types of immersion that we
only could have dreamed of in the past
you know the world of loading screens is
over and you know the days of you know
pop in and geometry popping up as you're
going through these game environments
are ended and the resulting effect is
the ability to build games they're fully
immersive from start to finish over you
know hundreds of hours of gameplay if
that's your game ya know uh incredible
what I think this is gonna enable we've
talked a lot about PS 5 we know
obviously unreal engine runs kind of
across all platforms including you know
mobile and PC and Xbox of course what's
your take on like what you're showing
here how is that gonna scale to you know
to other systems like this demo we're
seeing is that you know will that run on
the Xbox Series X will it run on PC how
will it be different can you guys give
us some context on that um well I mean
Unreal Engine 5 is going to run across
all of our separate platforms next
generation console current generation
consoles as well as mobile devices one
of the one of the key features that
we've been working on is being able to
build content once and deploy it across
devices so on higher-end Hardware where
we can support nanite directly we'll be
able to render scenes at the fidelity
that that you just saw like complexation
5 for say an Android or iOS mobile
device what we will be able to do is
have tools that help to scale that
content down so that you'll be able to
take the game that you built at the
fidelity level 4 console and bring it to
all other devices Tim do you have a
sense between like sort of all that you
know like Xbox Playstation all these
other systems like sort of you know
they've made somewhat different choices
also some similar ones obviously with
SSDs and both you have a sense of how
they're gonna sort of compare in terms
of power or you know what how you look
at sort of like the overall landscape
well you know we love all of our babies
and we can make comparisons or pick
favorites but then anti-technology we
showed here it's going to run across all
next generation consoles and high-end PC
and most importantly this is what's
possible and absolute best Hardware
around it's going to exist you know at
the end of the year but these
experiences you build we will help
developers scale down to every device
they're just in the world and we really
help and hope to empower all developers
to do what we've done with fortnight in
this generation which has built
absolutely no trick no sacrifices
high-end console game and then bring it
to every device including scaling it
down to iOS and Android devices from
years ago so that we can meet reach a
much much much larger audience of gamers
than you know just the hardcore you know
some 200 million console players in the
world so cam I know a lot of gamers
around the world watch that footage and
said wow I want to play that but I'm
sure they're also trying to kind of
extrapolate out of that since it's you
know this is not a game it's a demo you
know how their games are gonna feel
different in the next generation and one
of the things that I really took away
from it was that that flight sequence at
the end which was just incredible and
with you know the sort of the rubble
coming down and things moving could you
maybe talk about sort of how the game
experience might change with Yui 5 sure
it's gonna look you know visually more
beautiful but how is it gonna play
different so so traditionally on this
current generation if you wanted to make
a photorealistic environment the way
that people do that is they bake
lighting into the environment the
problem with that that means the
environment is not dynamic
you can't move things around you can't
incorporate user-generated content
because you don't know what it is prior
to
your game but with this technology with
the lumen technology and nana it means
that Wells can be super rich and super
dynamic so dis not not just destructible
components but mutating components and
things that change beyond the release of
the game everyday an environment could
have grown and changed and that can all
be calculated live and is that extend to
like you know I assume like destructible
environments so whatnot and allowing
people to sort of you know really like
just I mean I that sequence in the
flight where he serves you know saw the
four tower Crashdown or whatever I mean
that felt to me I mean I just hadn't
seen that level of detail in a game like
that and some games like Uncharted or
wherever sometimes have big destruction
moments but it felt like that was so
detailed and so realistic is that
partially because you can now move the
environment more in real time yes and
even effects like when we open that big
dome world statues off the light just
floods in and bounces all over the place
you know you you really the way you
we've had to do that in the past as you
would like to achieve and now it can be
fully dynamic you can blow a hole in the
skylight and the lion come through and
you know even choose randomly cover
planets if you put them into the scene
as a player then they're gonna have an
effect on the whole world and you'll
still look realistic
so in the past you could get that effect
but it would have to be sort of pre
calculated I guess what yeah even if you
weren't like if you were saying you're
in a dungeon and you play nice a light
you see you've got a candle that you
happen to have in the game and you place
it that will bounce around corners so
you can even you can explore with
limited light sources the old-fashioned
Ganic of having a flashlight beam isn't
what you need anymore you can actually
use lighting very interesting wise yeah
and you know even beyond Games Unreal
Engine has been you know applied to so
many amazing you know aspects of
entertainment of course you know I think
everyone knows the mandalorian how that
used Unreal Engine and you know there's
certainly the Weather Channel there's so
many other uses of Yui
can you guys talk about how sort of Yui
5 is going to you know kind of tie into
those experiences and I think you know I
assume you see this convergence of kind
of everything coming together through an
engine like unreal in terms of just
realizing entertainment
how will you e5 sort of you know be used
in those fields or how will how will
that change the pipeline for non game
you still so one of the great things
about nanite is that it finally allows
content creators of all kinds to be able
to use movie quality assets so there
really won't be a difference if you're
building an environment for a film
versus a video game or you're making an
IP that's transmedia you can build
things the same way now and that was
honest think that was you know we had so
much exposure to film customers over the
last few years
using our engine that we really wanted
to remove the barrier for them and for
all game makers right now you just you
pick a high resolution ass that you want
you loaded in you don't have to think
about making levels of detail or normal
maps or any of the usual stuff that goes
with making game content it's a pretty
freeing experience for anybody try not
trying to tell a story or to make an
experience that's amazing so you know in
the eyes of a consumer like you'll see
an asset that's in you know a movie and
that they literally can drag that over
the game now whereas I guess in the past
they would have to sort of you know
reduce down the polygons and kind of you
know kind of scale it down for a game
engine their assets they come when you
when you take an asset from the qixels
store there is a movie quality version
that would be used in movies you know
they I guess they were involved a lot in
the jungle book movie a few years ago
and many movies today use quick slot
sets and they also have versions of the
masses that are suitable for games now
there's you don't have to have that
distinction a night we'll just take the
movie asset and do the right things with
it one of the things I know when you
guys move to Yui for a lot of people you
know we're worried about oh it's you
know it's breaking some of the pipeline
of things that people had done
previously and it sounds like with this
engine you're saying it's gonna be kind
of a pretty seamless transition to Yui 5
right that's important for you sir have
the the Ford's compatibility yeah
absolutely
we want to support developers bringing
their games from ue4 to ue5 and in fact
we will be doing that ourselves with for
tonight so we will be shipping for
tonight on next-generation console on
Yui 4 and then next year we will be
bringing fortnight to Yui 5 as well so
we'll be testing out that experience of
bringing a game along from Huey 40 week
five and making sure the transition is
is manual is manageable Wow
yeah you know for tonight obviously such
a phenomenon as you mentioned earlier
Tim with you know bad Orioles but also I
feel like you know fortnight has turned
into you know really kind of this
Metaverse like platform where we're
seeing kind of different experiences
powered by Unreal and I was wondering if
you guys could talk a bit about that
because I look at you know the Travis
Scott concert and I see that as an
amazing experience but it sort of was an
interactive music video in a way and
then you know you watch the YouTube
video for his new song it's actually you
know just what was it unreal um how do
you see these all those sort of worlds
of entertainment combining Tim
longer-term and obviously based on what
Kim was saying it's now gonna be even
easier I guess for the assets to move
but from an experience standpoint do you
see kind of a blending of games with
more traditional entertainment powered
by unreal yeah absolutely
you know all of these worlds are
colliding right now in real-time we're
seeing the sort of a film production
that's being done on the mandalorian and
other projects all around a Hollywood
film and television you know being able
to move directly to games in the future
yeah right now we've brought Marvel
content into fortnight in Star Wars
content into fortnight and each of those
processes started with rebuilding their
their you know movie quality assets for
real time you know using our tools but
in the future that this is going to be
an exercise to build every asset exactly
once and then deploy it everywhere and
the future isn't just going to be about
Unreal Engine serving a bunch of
separate markets
we're helping architects visualize their
creations now and that's awesome
we're helping film and television makers
you know virtually produce their work in
real time you know with actors in front
of actresses and from cameras and and
big LED screens instead of green screens
and it's making the production process
much more efficient real time and higher
quality but you know in the in the
future all these assets are going to
come together and epics not going to
just play a role in supplying creation
software to
all these different industries we're
going to help everybody reach consumers
with real-time 3d content you know when
General Motors released their a Corvette
car configurator for the 2020 Corvette
it was powered by Unreal it was running
on the cloud and you could go there and
you could configure a your car right
then but um you know that was that was
disconnected from the rest of the gaming
world the next step with all of those
types of experiences is to enable them
to offer that content for all their
internal work whether you're building
designing a home for a customer as an
architect or you're designing a car or
you're building a television series we
want the next generation of these
experiences to be bringing all of those
assets directly to gamers in a fun way
deploying them into fortnight and every
other on your engine license use games
being able to reach a vast consumer
audience that way
right it's like a it's like the
transition that the world went through
in the early days of the internet um and
then social media you know for a while
it was just companies talking to
customers one on one and now it's you
have the ability to reach customers
directly to your Facebook page or your
Twitter page you know your Twitter
account anything like that but the next
generation these experiences is not just
text and video it's real-time 3d it's a
social experience where players together
our player players are together with all
of their friends and experiencing all
these companies content together in real
time it's a world it's not going to be
powered by advertisements that pop up
and annoy you it's a world it's going to
be powered by awesome content these
companies make available to power your
entertainment experiences and we're
blazing this path to some extent with
fortnight but there will be a lot of
other games heading in this direction
love them powered by Unreal Engine and I
think this is the next step in the
entire digital content industry not just
gaming but the whole thing I couldn't
agree more that's it's so exciting to
feel that games are gonna be at the
center of this but as you said I think
you know this like the shared
experiences that you're having in
fortnight even you know a concert
experience there's there's no gunplay or
combat involved it's just a shared kind
of experience which is so compelling and
as you said powered by Unreal and then
when you think of as you said those
movie assets and and and all the other
assets
together in a world it's it's really
exciting one thing I wanted to ask you
about was the content creation path
because we've seen a lot especially in
fortnight with you know creative mode
and a lot of you know fans of
fortnight's starting to build levels and
obviously Yui you guys I think of you
know really focused on kind of making it
accessible lowering the royalty rates
for kind of you know upstart developers
can you maybe talk a bit about sort of
the you know your vision of kind of how
easy it is to you know build something
in unreal I mean are we gonna get to a
level where it is sort of like you know
a Photoshop where you can kind of just
jump in and build a game or what is that
barrier to entry gonna go down in the
next generation
you know epic epic is working to address
the whole range of content development
scenarios Oh all the way from your
triple a game developer or your feature
film in Hollywood I'm being produced
using world-class photo real assets all
the way down to indie game experiences
and you know content creation for the
hundred million people who want to build
stuff that aren't professional modelers
and haven't had training in that and a
continuum of experiences spans you know
fortnight creative which has been used
by over 100 million people all the way
up to Unreal Engine 4 and the Unreal
editor which is an insanely powerful
piece of software that's actually pretty
complicated to learn over time these
these these tools and technologies will
be coming together in its some exciting
ways and we're not we're not ready to
talk about all of it yet but epic is
really thinking about putting a lot of
effort into addressing the entire
continuum of content development and
content deployment scenarios and you
know we feel that the state of the world
is a little bit broken right now if you
look at app stores on smartphones you
have 250,000 games each competing for
the top 10 charts where virtually all of
the sales occur and you have a smaller
number of winners and a whole lot of
losers in that way and it's not a fair
situation for game developers and you
have a lot of amazing games that just
get lost because they haven't been
discovered you know more and more we
want to enable content creators
reach the audiences within a distant
games and you know this is this has been
part of the industry since the days of
quake and unreal tournament when user
mods became possible and we and its
software released our first tools so the
community could start building their own
stuff and now it's reached a scale of
hundreds of millions of users if you
look at what fortnight is doing and
minecraft and roblox enabling User
Content creation but um I think I think
right now you have two separate worlds
right yeah the professional tools of
Unreal Engine and Yeti and then you have
the tools for the masses and fortnight
minecraft roblox and they're really not
connected right anymore they're not
connected at all and the next step is is
to crossover and to enable all the
content tools to reach all the customers
and all the ways that they play games
and there's something we're thinking a
lot about and we'll be doing will work
on and in the coming years it's awesome
to hear we've talked a lot obviously
about like graphics and you know
lighting and things that are you know
very powerful and visual that grab you
but I want to talk about the you know
the underlying architecture a little bit
and things especially like online
services and I know that's something
that you know epic is focused on about
kind of connecting people you know even
cross play but also you know finding
ways to kind of bring communities
together and I guess some of that's tied
to Yui 5 but also it's just a general
platform approach but can you maybe
share a bit on kind of your vision on
you know the other aspects of unreal and
epic and and how that's gonna sort of
evolve over the next few years - ok
today we're showing Unreal Engine 5 for
the first time but we're launching the
epic online services to all developers
in the world across five platforms right
now and you can download the epic online
services SDK and use it right away what
this is is the set of all of the online
features that we built for fortnight
including cross-platform friends that
stand seven platforms enable and enable
players get together with all of their
friends everywhere you know despite the
different account systems and friends
systems they're just on each platform
you know in the console platforms and on
Steam
and we're opening it up to all
developers for free and that the goal
here is is to help all developers work
together to accomplish what we would
accomplish with fortnight and to build a
cross-platform socialism together with
all of the other developers in the
industry right I'm instead of instead of
players being siloed into the you know
into the one platform they're playing on
the indie we want them to be able to
reach all of their friends everywhere
but also build up friends across
multiple games and that's the really
interesting thing about the epic account
services that we're launching if you
choose to use epic accounts in your game
then you can reach the entire fortnight
player base which is a over 350 million
accounts worldwide and more importantly
it's 2.2 billion social connections
between players you know when two
players become online friends and start
playing together there's a those friend
connections now persist across games you
know from all of the different
publishers it used to use these services
and so you know it's it's the most
openness how services they've been
launched to date and it really helps to
bridge the gap you know that suggested
all the other other platforms and until
recently it was really only epic yeah
activision the really big companies with
a huge set of development resources that
had the capability of building that sort
of thing but now this is open and to
proved by all three of the console
makers for use on their on their
platforms and it's ready for all game
developers to adopt and so we're so
we're really trying to to help the
industry get to a better place and we
think you know the core of the game
industry are these you know 300 million
hardcore gamers across high-end PC and
you know in console but there are
billions of gamers worldwide and I think
the next stage of the industry's growth
is going to come from connecting these
audiences you know not with little n
casual games and went to platforms and
high-end games and another set of
platforms but getting all the players to
play together and ain't blowing our
developers to release their games in all
platforms as we did with fortnight yeah
I think that's such an interesting idea
that you know these these gaming
platforms
come you know it's another social
network now right and I know you guys
have house party that's been very
successful over the past few months
especially but it feels like now you
know you talked to those numbers with
epical online services it starts to feel
like this is you know a Twitter or
snapchat or an Instagram and sort of
this way to kind of connect people is
that part of your longer-term vision is
that people will use sort of these
game-game services as as kind of a
gateway to connect with people and any
you know games are a part of it but also
just the larger sort of social graph
will be kind of the gateway to it will
be through a game engine well you know
what we're building here is the opposite
of a walled garden right where we're
enabling all publishers to use all of
their different account systems and and
connect using these services and we're
working with all the different console
makers too and other platforms and
services to help interconnect them
you're the most interesting thing about
this and if you look is if you start
playing for tonight on PlayStation and
then you want to play the game on the
iOS device on iOS you can log in with
your PlayStation account and then you
get all of your PlayStation Progress
transferred over if you start playing on
PC then you create an epic account then
if you go to Xbox then you can log in
with your epic account on your xbox and
so this isn't a walled garden rather
it's an attempt to connect all the
different services you know so which are
have different degrees of openness and
and I think that's that's really going
to be freeing for the industry it's
going to mean that everybody can talk to
everybody else and there's no one
company I'm controlling the whole thing
rather it's a it arises as a result of
the cooperation between all the
different companies in the ecosystem who
finally realize that they can grow
better and build better businesses if
instead of trying to let players into
their platforms they enable their
players check with all of their friends
across all platforms because uh you know
we have a lot of devices in our lives
and everybody who has a an Xbox or a
PlayStation also has an iPhone or an
Android device um and and you know to
really enable the next generation of
industry growth we've got to be able to
connect all of these users with all
these friends and set aside had the old
feuds that defined
previous generations of the console
business so with everything you're
describing I think of you know a show
like the mandalorian which you know we
all watched and loved but all those
assets are there I mean they're nothing
prevents them now from building kind of
an interactive experience I guess around
that that they could power with
something like unreal and you know maybe
it's a game but maybe it's just sort of
this shared experience and it feels like
you know that the visual fidelity now
that these next-gen consoles will bring
I mean based on what you were saying Kim
and Nick it's like our thing's gonna
look just like movie visual effects like
what are the things that I guess
real-time games can't do still that we
get to see in some of these other shows
you know I think I think we'll get much
much closer for this generation to get
to the point where you're not going to
be able to tell the difference between a
virtual world and a real world there's
still you know physical phenomenon big
massive explosions and you know waves
crashing on a beach I think they're
they're still a little but we won't
generation not before they're perfect
but we're getting closer and closer and
one of the coolest things that we've
seen with the advent of shows like the
Mandalorian stars use the engine is they
were beginning to understand that a game
engine isn't just a wrap about rendering
pretty real time pixels their
understanding their game engines
especially unreal is built for building
these very immersive simulated worlds so
we're seeing people say they've got a
car chase in their TV show that they're
trying to make then they'll actually
drive cars with steering wheels and
joypads to race against each other and
then film that after the fact so it
started to become very um almost like
very matrix work way in though in the
way that they're using simulation for a
cinematic content creation and I think
that's just gonna get more and more
common and as they start to rock the
potential of what real-time interactive
entertainment is about I think you're
gonna see traditional storytellers
making them move into video games and if
and back wasn't forward I think you're
gonna see this very very fuzzy world
where we're it's just entertainment
you're building an IP it can be a game
it can be a TV show it can be all these
things and it's it's gonna be a pretty
exciting decade and I'm sure some people
saw that you know the showcase that you
guys just showed that the demo but
everyone's like I want to play that game
but we should clarify that's that
not a game I don't think right it's just
detect them up it's a demo we feel is
that like the best way to present
especially something that was built for
the game developer conference is to show
something within the context of gameplay
so what and it also means you know we
wanted to improve some animation systems
in the engine so it was much better to
actually have a world that you can walk
through play jump whatever keeps it
keeps it real or unreal in this case I
say it's it's real gameplay that's what
we like to like to see is that people
can actually play through that and again
it's it just blows me away when you see
that final sequence at the flight and
that's the kind of thing that I think
we've all been waiting for is to see
that glimpse of where games are are
going next so it's it's really exciting
to see how you guys keep pushing the you
know pushing the technology to the next
level with Yui 5 and I know it's gonna
be next year you say so we'll see some
next gen games this holiday shipping on
you know brand you know Yui 4.25 I think
right and then next year is when we'll
see you in five is that right yeah
that's right we're planning on having a
preview of uv5 available early next year
and then shipping the full 5.0 later in
the year yeah
and I imagine you know characters will
also improve I know you guys have done a
lot of work there was sort of you know
character technology we already talked
about with Nick you know the idea of you
know streaming more into the environment
you know no load times as Tim mentioned
I mean these are other things that I
guess are gonna you know sort of impact
the game experience but are there other
dimensions that you think you know the
next generation will sort of evolve to
with ue5 I mean I think the character
stuff feels like to me another area
where you know we're not quite the same
as you know movies yet in terms of
character technology but I'm sure you
guys are pushing on that too I'm very
competitive this is just the tip of the
iceberg here you know we've we've shown
digital humans technology in the past
but a epic and the three lateral team
that recently joined us are are going to
be pushing that to entirely new levels
I'm not just in graphics fidelity but
also in productivity for content
creators so that you know at all
without a huge budget can build digital
humans that are world class and we have
a lot of investments going on - you're
here about over the coming months and
over the next year you know also at the
core of this this isn't a big open world
demo but open world technology enabling
worlds without balance is the key an
issue that's uniting all of this
virtualized geometry is one part of it
glommit global elimination lilamon is
another part of it but ultimately this
comes together to empower you huge
streaming seamless environments and that
and that creates an entirely new
direction for games to go and remember
this is not just a this is not just a
graphic Center I use the full simulation
engine aims to power every aspect of
simulating realistic environment I'm
including very detailed physics vehicles
in collision and destruction and
everything else I think you will see a
qualitatively different set of games for
the new generation and what we have here
and it's going to be very exciting
because we don't yet know exactly what
they're going to be and how does you
know you guys mentioned Fortnight moving
to ue5 next year like I mean how how is
this gonna impact you know or tonight do
you think in terms of like the game with
Yui 5 if you don't spoil much but it's
like just technically sort of like is
that going to enable the game to evolve
- well it puts a vast amount of an
additional a new power in and all of
their creators who build for tonight
both within epic and you know the
hundred million or so outside yeah it'd
be very interesting to see to see where
this enables the game to go in the
future I think what we have now it's a
it's a very very small fraction of what
the game will be in the future and you
know it's going to be very exciting to
see the fortnight team a team of all of
it and have all this new power in their
hands what I see it is you know it's a
game but it also feels like a platform
in a way that it's enabling you know
these other extreme know this battle
royale game but there's creative and
obviously we started to see you know
other experiences with music artists and
whatnot around it so it feels like it is
the
you know this beach head just sort of a
bunch of other content is that how you
view it is sort of this you know sort of
this and people have used the term you
know you know sort of Metaverse but is
that sort of the longer term vision is
that fortnight can sort of grow to
whatever creators want to take it define
a platform as a as an ecosystem in which
the most of the content is not created
by the by the company that operates it
right and I think if you look at
fortnight today it's not that but
anything's possible in the future I
think that's a that's a very interesting
direction for the whole game business
every game the Opera thing about this
problem of how to not limit their
experience by the ten or a hundred or a
thousand people on their development
team but how to uncap the entire world's
creativity to enable an entirely new
generation of game experiences to be
developed in an entirely new way yeah
well I think ue5 obviously shows the
high end of the aspiration for everyone
to you know what they'll eventually be
able to maybe make and yeah that demo is
absolutely stunning i before we go I
want to ask you like that demo how long
did it take you guys to build how many
people worked on give us a sense of like
you know how that came to life well we
started thinking about it
straight after GDC was when we started
thinking about it when you Brian's
Brian's nanotechnology was beginning to
come online and but the bulk of the work
I would say the bulk of the work started
from sort of September through to March
and I think the team you know it peaked
over this but I think it was about two
dozen people that worked on the project
overall and with a bit of help from our
friends at quick sole if it hadn't been
for the qixels game library we couldn't
be able to populate that world
yeah well that's I'm sure everyone looks
at that and says I want to play that
game and I know we're not necessarily
gonna get it but it hopefully will
inspire a lot of creators around the
world about what will be possible you
know with Yui 5 and also the next
generation system so yeah I I feel real
excited now about we're gonna get to see
for the rest of the year for all these
next gen games and of course into the
future thanks as always for for joining
me guys
it's great to see the first look at ue5
and hear about where epics going and
yeah the future looks quite bright
thanks guys cool thank you thanks for
[Music]
you
you